sorry a badess bless I'm at us bless
what the family's sitting down front
like that okay so Tom Hanks may have won
big at the Golden Globes on Sunday
taking home the Cecil B deMille Award
but it's his son Chet Hanks that has
everyone losing their freakin minds and
frankly hella confused bigger big up the
whole island massive it's cowboy chetana
coming straight from that Golden Gloves
or10 signify that so amongst peasants in
an hour watch so far what come bigger
tune in
yeah that's Chet it's cowboy Peppa not
the actor slash musician posted the clip
to his Instagram on Sunday and yeah chut
speaking with a killer Caribbean accent
from the Golden Gloves red carpet
wriggle while some fans were left
scratching their heads
his mom Rita Wilson hit up the comments
calling it quote the best laugh of the
night meanwhile CNN named the video the
quote most bizarre moment of the 2020
Golden Globes which got shut back on
Instagram blessing us with this
follow-up post
we got the U of them we're out the
King's time we wake up this one and then
we see the king tunnel infinite but mine
respected unknown this one far but I got
you guys
I am shook Chet also shared a screenshot
of CNN's article which included a
headline reading Tom Hanks's son Chet is
filmed speaking patois at the Golden
Globes and the Internet is baffled chat
captioned his post quote average
citizens damn this is scary I can't
believe we're on the verge of World War
3 let me check the news shaking my head
at CNN yeah and he included a lot of
crying laughing emojis like a lot but
still no explanation for why he's doing
the accent anyhoo the 29 year old
attended the Globes to support his dad
who during his acceptance speech
emotionally saluted his family for their
support throughout his career I'm a
después what the family sitting down
front like that a wife who is fantastic
in every way who has taught me what love
is five kids who are braver and stronger
and wiser than their old man is and the
support is mutual
when et sat down with Chet in 2018 he
got candid about how his famous parents
helped him overcome addiction of course
your parents Tom Hanks Rita Wilson how
they supported you through your sobriety
just dumped by doing just that just just
by being supportive yeah you know and
and they couldn't be more supportive do
you know I mean it they every step of
the way you know I mean they've they've
always been there for me
lucky do they love seeing you as a dad
and this new side of you I mean you're
gonna be three years sober next month
yeah they really do and they love being
grandparents too it's awesome seeing
them being been grandparents as well
because I was really close with my
grandparents and now my daughter gets to
have the same experience
what are they like as grandparents what
do they what do they do with your little
one oh you know just just just regular
stuff just you know stuff around the
house hanging out spending time taking
care taking care of her you know does
she have a Toy Story woody doll that
needs to happen thanks everybody that
doesn't need to happen ray same buddy
over here yes yeah
do they ever offer to babysit yeah all
the time how cute is that but more
importantly who else is Matt impressed
with Chet's accent just me okay
Bravo Chet of course you can count on et
to bring you all the latest news from
Chet Tom Rita and the whole famous fam
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
[Music]